so yeah this one's a little more
specialized in that the people I was
having coffee with this morning we're
all physicists and this is really an
astronomer symbol not a physicist symbol
and in fact it's a symbol that's so
little used in the rest of physics that
actually when I ask them what the lapsim
would look like none of them could tell
me rather less well known symbol so I've
got to pull one from the Greek alphabet
this time this is the Greek letter
epsilon looks really rather like a
seagull it's kind of usually drawn
something like that and depending on
which front you're using it may have a
little bar at the bottom so that's the
Greek letter epsilon and it's used by
astronomers in particular to measure a
quantity called the max to light ratio
which is really just the ratio between
the mass of an object and the amount of
light it gives out as usually measured
in solar units so in these units the Sun
comes out as one because it's one solar
mass divided by one solar luminosity
which gives you one but the beauty of it
is if you took a thousand stars like the
Sun and stuck them all stuck them all
together and then then you figured out
the max to light ratio of that you'd
have a thousand times the mass of the
Sun divided by a thousand times the
luminosity of the Sun which is still one
because a thousand over a thousand is
one so really measuring the mass the
light ratio is telling you what
something is made of if I take a billion
stars like the Sun and stick them all
together to make a galaxy it's matched
to light ratio you would still expect to
come out as one we when we first started
looking at galaxies I guess this kind of
work was first done in the in the 1970s
in the mid to late 1970s people start
first started measuring these quantities
for galaxies and they were expecting the
answers to come out about one because
you know the galaxies made up of stars
pretty much like the Sun and so expected
the answer to come out to be one but
when we actually went and measured it
that's not what we found we were getting
answers like 10 or 20 or 30 which tells
you that there's an awful lot more mass
associated with galaxies than just what
we were expecting from stars like the
Sun and this was really some of the
first really strong evidence that the
universe is full of this stuff that we
called dark matter things that gives out
no light at all but has lots of mass
associated with it
so much higher higher numbers indicating
some kind of diluting force exactly it
tells you that something else there
that's something else adding to the mass
that's not adding to the light so you
add a bigger number in the top no no
bigger number in the bottom in your
fraction mass-to-light ratio and so
epsilon gets to be very big does it ever
go the other way though
so there are some things which have at
lower master light ratio so for example
very very massive stars mass stars that
maybe 10 or 20 times as massive as the
Sun can easily be a thousand or 10,000
times as bright so very massive stars
have enormous amounts of light and
although they are more massive than the
Sun not that much more massive so they
can have massive light ratios at a
fraction of one point 1.01 but they're
the exception rather than the rule